so you know it's fun that at sixty years
old I can learn a new saying I was in
Australia I was talking to some
Australians and they were asking me
about Rupert Murdoch who's Australian
who started Fox News so what do you
think about it I said what do y'all
think about him and they said well we
have this saying in Australia called
tall poppy and I'm like I had never
heard that and apparently there's a
thing only all the way back to Greek
mythology that says that in a poppy
field when one of the poppies sticks its
head up and gets to be taller than the
other poppies that someone cuts it down
and so the Australian saying is if
someone becomes famous or someone
becomes wealthy or someone succeeds we
feel like we have to cut them down you
ever heard of that in America we don't
call it tall poppy but we do it all the
time like we teach people be diligent
save your money work hard be excellent
at your job but for God's sakes don't
succeed because if you succeed then
you're an evil rich person that's tall
poppy syndrome right it's the same thing
and it's it's it's one of the most evil
sins that are out there one of the
deadly sins of seven deadly sins is envy
jealousy is I want what you have envy is
I don't think I can have it so I don't
want you to have it
you cannot celebrate someone else's
success ever when you have envy that's
tall poppy syndrome anyone who becomes
successful we relish in the idea that
they must be torn down we relish in the
idea that oh if he or she has built
wealth if he or she has become
successful and they're chosen gotten
into the spotlight because of their
success then they must be evil and they
must be brought down and we are somewhat
gleeful when they crash or when someone
can crash them and so we're always
looking for something to be pissed off
about when it comes to the successful
the wealthy and that and that's
immaturity it's sin it's called envy and
creeps into politics you know this whole
thing of everybody needs to have the
same income socialism crap you know
everybody's not gonna have the same
income because everybody doesn't work as
hard as everybody else everybody's not
as smart as everybody else I'm not as
smart as people who make more money than
me
there are people smarter than me they
make less money because they don't do
anything with their intelligence but
there are people from are a lot smarter
than me they make a lot more money than
me and I'm not mad about that I'm gonna
do what I can do with what I got I'm not
gonna be on the cover of GQ magazine I
got a face for radio so the chances of
me making it big as a male model is zero
unless they need an oompa loompa okay so
I'm okay with that I'm gonna work with
what I got but if you want it you know
if somebody is a beautiful person and
they can make money off of that I'm not
there's nothing wrong with that things
are not equal in this world and so
incomes and wealth are not gonna be
equal in this world
get over yourself you're not do squat
you're not entitled to anything little
snowflake so I bring that up because I
got this this article came across my
desk and it's just interesting Jeff
Bezos one of the wealthiest people in
the world just bought David Geffen's
house for a hundred and sixty five
million dollars in Los Angeles the
all-time LA home purchase record hundred
and sixty-five million dollars
can you imagine most of us can't no I
can't imagine did Jeff do something
wrong you could have spent a whole lot
of starving people for that you evil
rich person you're so wasteful well let
me tell you how you can check yourself
on this kind of thing and I had to learn
to do this cuz I I know a lot of people
in my own neighborhood a lot of people I
grew up with not all of them but some of
them they just like you know they want
to they want to have tall poppy syndrome
they just want to tear down anybody
who's rich anybody who's done well I
don't I'm not I don't know Jeff Bezos
from beans I don't know what kind of
character the man has I'm not defending
that at all I'm defending his right to
make 100
sixty-five million dollar purchase on a
home because here's the ratios that's
like the average American family as a
ratio of his debt him spending 165
it's like the typical person listening
to me right now buying something for one
hundred and twenty two dollars that's
how big a decision this was for him it
wasn't it wasn't sweat off of his brow
he didn't think about it
he didn't wring his hands and wonder if
he could afford it any more than you do
when you spend a hundred and twenty-two
dollars on a night out of the dinner and
some of you spend that at a pizza place
feeding your whole freaking tribe right
so hey before you start judging someone
else on what they've spent something on
do some ratios and it'll keep your it'll
keep your spirit straight it'll keep you
from falling into the sin of envy which
is I don't think I can have what you
have and so I don't want you to have it
now I think the probability of Dave
Ramsey ever buying 165 million dollar
house is very low because I don't think
I will build the level of wealth in my
lifetime that Bezos was built I don't
see it in my future
maybe I should think bigger maybe I'd
had a better vision maybe so forth but I
probably won't be able to do that and I
certainly won't be able to do it on the
ratios that he did it on but I'm able to
do some really nice things that I never
dreamed as a little kid I would get to
do and I get hate mail for that day
Ramsey made all his money on the backs
of poor people I don't think so I didn't
force anybody to do anything I haven't
stolen any money from anybody and yet
some of you people get completely
twisted up I can't believe you spent
that well it's not any of your freakin
business to start with but you're
falling into that sin of envy and as
long as you hate successful people it
will be very difficult for you to become
one
it's very difficult psychologically for
you to work very hard to become
something you detest and so teaching our
children that wealth is evil teaching
our children that wealth Peete wealthy
people are evil inherently because they
have money teaching our children that
becoming successful causes you to that
you should be torn down
tall poppy syndrome it's it's really bad
medicine in America today teaching you
that you should make money because you
breathe air that you deserve a universal
minimum wage horse crap
you don't deserve nothing a guy in my
office one day a few years ago come in
he's got all these degrees he's been to
like six different degrees or whatever
he's got more degrees than a thermometer
working for us and he's like Dave guys
that got degrees like me we make a whole
lot more than I make here and I said
well you should go get that job he said
what do you mean I said well this is a
small business man here's the way it
works here your raise is effective when
you are when you get up leave the cave
kill something and drag at home money I
will share it with you or if you want go
do it on your own I'll be your biggest
cheerleader I don't care either way but
this idea that your your do money
because you have a degree bullcrap
you're due money because you breathe air
oh crap you're not doing nothing you
know do squats snowflake buckle up
buttercup go get something done then you
deserve it leave the cave kill something
and drag it home prove you have value in
the marketplace but there's a reason
that people don't get paid much of
McDonald's because any idiot can work
there it's the bottom of the food chain
no pun intended you know I'm not mad at
McDonald's but if you can't flop a
whopper
you really have fairly low skills get
you some skills baby and don't be mad at
Jeff Bezos he spent a hundred and
twenty-two dollars compared to you so
don't be envious of him and tearing him
down the people ripping on Bezos over
this and again I'm not defending Jeff
Bezos I don't know him I have no idea
about his personal life or
character I don't know what his business
practices are behind the scenes I know
he owns Amazon only ones half the world
right now I'm not mad about that either
I didn't invent Amazon it's not my money
if I had come up with it I'd cash the
check because it's obviously serving a
lot of people even if you don't agree
with it you're buying from them all the
time obviously so you paid for that
house because he provided you a service
so stop you're tall poppy syndrome stop
the Envy it's evil it's evil go be
productive